AOC was on 60 minutes last night quite a
feat for a newcomer must be all her
great new ideas people are gonna have to
start paying their fair share in taxes
once you get to like the tippy tops I'm
your 10 millionth dollar
sometimes you see tax rates as high as
60 or 70 percent what an expression now
the real story is an AO sees very old
ideas it's the media's gushie view of
her even with her old ideas she gets on
60 minutes the past is called the future
and you better love it take a OCS
delightful dancing video from last week
the media created a fake story that
conservatives attacked her over this
delightful trifle not really in fact the
only stories written about the dance
were by liberals using it to falsely
smear the right so the press creates a
shield around her in which any criticism
must be due to sexism or bigotry when in
fact it's in their heads and not ours
but the strategy works by preventing
real criticism about her actual beliefs
which are retread of horrible ideas from
previous centuries socialism with a
smile fascism among friends
Venezuela meets beggin beggin the sad
news is that we have proof of such
utopian nightmares
Satur news so many young people don't
care socialism is a brand that happily
reinvents itself with every naive
generation a o'seas fans like to say
she's living in our heads like pharell
Williams singing happy but in fact it's
the policies that live in our heads and
they should live there because we know
so many people who've been brutalized by
such ideas when you hear someone talk
about socialism like it's a fun new way
to pay down my college debt you got a
scream just prepare to be called awful
things for doing so today pointing out
the evil of the past makes you the bane
of the present you know Jessie you know
what I love this here's the left
suddenly they want to return to the
1950s the socialist playbook I do think
she's very talented on social media and
she's got a big following but she's now
a member of Congress as a Democrat and
there's certain rules as a Democrat that
you have to play by now she's just a
freshman she has to realize Pinocchio's
are for Donald Trump
can't be so sloppy she's getting fat
checked all the time by the Washington
list did you really mean you're putting
her down by comparing to Trump no I'm
saying that the only reason he's
complimenting her in the Washington Post
fat checks her more than Donald Trump
it's a problem for the Democrats also
she's also so out there politically that
the Republicans can now use her as a
wedge issue against their own party and
the leadership hates that she's also hot
dogging Nancy Pelosi she's starting to
steal her thunder and a lot of people in
leadership are saying hey slow down a
little bit let's let's be honest this
reminds me of a rookie you know a great
college career now they got drafted top
draft pick they enter the league and
giving the opposite opposing teams a lot
of bulletin board material kind of a bad
with chemistry in the locker room a lot
of the vets on the team don't really
like her that much getting called for a
lot of personal fouls on the field
she's in page six alive you know she
might burn out but she might have a long
career we don't really know yes he let
me just point some things at you one she
voted for Nancy Pelosi and then the
Republicans hissed at her because guess
what is gold for Republicans they are
making her least are not really
emma-crats it's Republicans who love her
because her organs didn't put her on 60
minutes yeah I think they did because
they give her so much attention that 60
minutes who is this she's wrong security
how about that remember when that was
radical oh yeah public society terrible
what about raising tax rates under
President Roosevelt president I wanna
throw in with the 70 percent tax rate
you can check voluntarily pay if you
take more than 10 million and you have
no objection to the fact that under
trump right now the deficit is blowing
sky you don't even mention he'll never
get to ten million if he's like that by
the way the rich pay now more than ever
I think that the top 1% pays 40 percent
total tax in 1980 it was 19 percent so
it's gotten a lot worse and it's not
actually affecting the debt whatsoever I
want to go to this interesting thing it
does enough we're still it we're still
being totally debts it has been
increasing radically that's not that's
my point it doesn't matter how much it
tax people in fact I've argued stop
taxing people it doesn't matter because
you because we are now spending addicts
right if you stop if you stop taxing our
country for one year it what would blue
what thirty four trillion dollars
wouldn't we even care that would be
great we'd all save all of our money and
we'd be in debt but we don't care I want
to live it we live in anarchy well you
love that's not Anarchy Dana okay one
thing I noticed is a comparison and a
correlation Donald Trump AOC comes in
calls out the establishment Democrats
you get Whoopi Goldberg on the view
saying hello hold your horses lady you
know they're a bunch of Democrats before
you a thousand Democrats who work their
butts off to get this and that isn't
that a pretty fair course people that
were voting for
rats in deep blue districts like a OCS
we're definitely saying that there since
they're done with the status quo think
about the Bernie bros yeah the Bernie
bros wanted some they didn't want
Hillary Clinton Hillary Clinton didn't
win because I'm not enough Democrats
wanted her to come out and win I knew
that Nancy Pelosi at some point would be
eclipsed by this younger generation
I just didn't know it would happen in
three days yeah that is that's pretty
interesting the other thing is a OC beat
one of Pelosi's most ardent allies in
the Congress she owes Pelosi nothing
yeah and yes she might but I do think
Jesse makes a great point let that the
more she actually talks about the ideas
not her personally not the dancing of it
but the ideas right that you could
retrofit all of America within ten years
with renewable energy like policy wise
you have to go okay
that's not possible and she would say
why not just say it every day she's got
to build the wall comment right she goes
wage she goes for it Emily every time I
think the upside is when she's talking
about like socialism in Sweden or she's
talking about seventy percent rates it
reminds other people to go read up on
this stuff and find out the truth you
know totally which in Sweden it's a
violent reality yes Sweden is absolutely
going down in flames there's parallel
societies true I gotta give Greg one
reason by 40% hundred percent jump in
her take it a step further I think the
the use of as analogy a culturally
formerly homogeneous society in a tiny
country is not accurate it's right
applicable here that's kind of
ridiculous and I think for aoc her time
to be popular is over now is her time to
get to work she already won so there I
think it would it like everyone we could
all benefit from specificity and
accuracy in Congress so it would only
help her further and further her cause
and and the people that could rally to
hi even if she doesn't isn't owed
anything by anyone or she doesn't know I
think there's a certain amount of OMA
she should pay by by being specific and
accurate
and not so a one day she is going for
her everybody wants to have a beer with
her